all right so the boys season two we're
through five episodes we got three left
i think it's
it's safe to say not as good as the
first season comparatively speaking it's
pretty weak and
i feel like we're in heroes season two
territory with the boys season two what
is it with superhero shows why is that
the case why are they like whoa season
one we crushed it
we didn't know there's going to be a
season two um all right let's just
have the characters go on ark so we
don't really know what to do with them
and that will definitely show but we'll
create a lightning lady hopefully that's
enough which to be fair
stormfront's one of the more compelling
characters of this season but yeah i
think the season has flaws there are a
lot of cracks in the armor
in that universe in the universe of the
boys after the first three episodes i
did my video on that and i was like oh
people know about compound v and you
know
i'm glad that they're moving the story
forward respect ever be great at
hindsight like i am
after the fact i'll do something or say
something and after it's too late after
i send the text or
the phone call's done i'll be like uh or
i do that all the time so that happened
with that video it was like video live i
was like
oh unless them putting compound v out
there and people knowing about it's
gonna
take away from some of the tension in
the show but i'll address that if that
seems to be the case well now i'm
addressing it because it seems to be the
case see for me in season one one of the
things i really liked about it and i get
it this is totally subjective but i feel
like i'm probably not alone here
is the fact that there's a super shady
organization
but everybody loved them everyone loves
vot but we know they're [ __ ]
and then they're these morally
compromised
superheroes but everyone loves them we
know they're [ __ ] but people are like no
they're great the seven for life but we
know because our crew knows
butcher knows the boys they know so
they're the peak behind the curtain that
we get we actually know the truth and we
see everybody just taking the bait and
falling for it it is unwinnable
they're unbeatable because public
perception of them is so
positive any move you make against them
you're gonna be the [ __ ] even though
you know you're taking on super villains
not superheroes it just shows the power
of public perception
but now there are a lot of cracks in the
armor for vots and the seven because
everyone knows compound v they know it's
the super illegal drug that vought paid
parents to give their kids
to make them superheroes so people know
vots shady now now in this episode we
see there's a cell phone video of
homelander
laser eyeing this bad guy and then up
collateral damage he kills a civilian
too
that's cellphone footage out there
people they know that
they start losing faith in homelander
he's down nine points or something like
that what point what is he running for
president what i don't know well he got
half the points back anyway so right
there there are a lot of cracks in the
armor that all happened at the same time
if like if there was a cell phone video
of homeland or killing somebody
that people didn't know about compound v
that'd be one thing or they found out
about compound v so you know public
perception maybe
vots kind of taken a hit but people
still love homelander that's what i
thought it was going to be i thought it
was going to be
homelander and the seven taking the
sight of the people against vod because
it looked like that in the first three
episodes or whatever he's like we are
not vaught i was like ooh
he's he's actually siding with people
though he doesn't care about people but
it would still
save face for the eyes of the people in
the eyes of the people then homelander
killed someone on a cell phone i guess
not but there's no consistency in the
universe because people are still
looking forward to this
dawn of seven movie you know like if
there was an actor celebrity whoever
take your pick pick
one in your mind's eye they were making
a movie
and they had a franchise and then there
was cell phone video of them committing
manslaughter i feel like production of
that would grind to a halt but it's like
people care and they they're losing
faith in homelander in this season or
this episode at least
but then that movie's still being made
like that would be a whole
thing and they didn't even touch on that
it was just like people hate homelander
for a hot
second and then that's that brandon
maybe they're creating a point where
they're like oh well
jokes on twitter that will cost someone
a career
or a job but not actual violence like we
hold jokes
to a higher standard than violence maybe
so it's either lazy writing or
they're making that point i don't know
but occam's razor says it's
probably lazy writing so when going
further with the point of there not
being consistency in this season
of the boys in season two black noir has
followed butcher to this house
and so they plant all these home alone
bombs and black noirs tripping them all
and then they kind of get into a
showdown with black noir in which
butcher's like hey i have pictures of
homelanders kid let us go
or i just release them on the internet
but there are a couple things there one
i think we finally found out why
camiko's been wasted all season again
looked like ooh they're gonna go
an interesting route with her because
stormfront killed her brother
now also season one left us off with
those super terrorists out there
no she goes off on her own frenchie
follows her because they don't know what
to do with either of them and she turns
out she's a hit man and our friend
friend she starts lecturing her like
this is not the way it's like dude
she has killed more people than you i'm
pretty sure or at least
the people she's killed they've been in
more brutal fashion than you've ever
done she ripped a guy's [ __ ] face off
for christ's sex have you ripped a face
off no i did not think so reminded me of
the fly too
when the fly vomits all the you know the
digestive [ __ ] on the guy's face his
face could
anyhow it's the fly too it doesn't
matter i think it's on youtube if you
want to check it out
it's there but i think they sent her
away
because in the round table of
brainstorming for season two they were
like oh we want to have this moment with
black noir it's like well is she there
because
if kamiko's there then she'll probably
fight noir because they're both supes
and they can do that granted noir might
kick her ass
because they've been in a fight before
it didn't really work out too well for
her
but the point is if she's there butcher
won't have his whole like
oh i'm gonna take one for the team thing
and maybe he'll die and maybe he won't
i'll say that about this season every
every character is kind of equally
useless so i don't know
if they're going to kill anybody it's
always on the table in my mind like ooh
this person might die
because they've kind of done jack [ __ ]
this season so there is that so i really
do feel like that's the reason for them
sending
her away on her quest of no quest at all
so they can have this
moment with black noir where they're
clearly overpowered
and so butch was like hey here's the
blackmail i have these pictures
of homelanders son and if you don't
leave us alone
that [ __ ] will go out there on the
internet in which i guess vots pretty
stupid
because all you all right it's like oh
you don't want these pictures going out
there
it'll make you look bad it'll make
homelander look bad here's the thing
vaught already looks bad because
everyone knows about compound v and
homelander already looks bad because
there's a
there's video of him killing somebody
granted i guess people will know that
homelander rape butcher's wife but
they won't really i mean that's what
you'll say it is but this wanted
terrorist on the news is saying that
it's kind of
he said he said kind of thing it's also
the third damaging thing in the eyes of
the people that vat will come across
this season also ivaat has any brains
whatsoever they'll be like all right so
he just threatened us
with a mom and a kid that nobody even
knows about
who are isolated in this big jurassic
park pen
nobody even knows where that is it's all
right noir go to that house
kill butcher's wife bring the kid back
here to vot and
reunite him with homelander and our spin
will be yes
homelander has a kid with a lady he
loved very dearly
but kept her out of the limelight
because she didn't want to be in public
life
and she died of cancer very tragic
that'll be it good job showing your
cards there butcher how is vot not going
to do that
tomorrow i feel like that would be the
logical move for them i know i
tried to keep it open-minded optimistic
appraisal of the situation going okay
maybe this will iron itself out but
season two is just it's not season one
at the end of every episode i'm always
left with that same reaction i'm like
that's it
all right well that's today's video i
guess i don't know hopefully it makes
for fun videos for you
here on my channel when i talk about it
but just the boys season two
i kind of see as that sequel lightest
that season two effect that i've
seen other shows go through i mean
granted this episode still had cool
things just like this season has had
cool things
homelander laser eyeing an entire crowd
was like
this is either the last season they do
ever or this is not
actually happening and it's in his
imagination turns out it's in his
imagination still was a pretty sweet
scene and i feel like that
could very well happen eventually i mean
the thing that keeps homelander from
eradicating a lot of people i feel like
his public perception he loves being
loved but if that gets taken away like
it looks like it's happening in this
season
he might just snap what's he got to lose
really it was elizabeth's shoe she kept
him at bay this new girl
dude no he doesn't respect her he
doesn't listen to her
she works for him but hey homelander
finally lasered those titties the
homelander in stormfront they [ __ ]
so there's that there's three episodes
left that's three hours in which they
could have it all come together in a way
that's
actually compelling that definitely does
work but thus far it ain't season one
maybe it's because i'm coming right off
a cobra kai
that's a good binge all right so the
boys season two episode five have you
seen it why did you think about it
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you